Celestia is with us in Tucson Arizona hi
how are you great good my husband and I
just paid off our student loans right I
mean we have one got laugh Rio 10,000
the Wells Fargo my husband has called
them three times and often to felt when
T percent but they're refusing not they
say 40 percent I'm wondering is it
reasonable to hold out the 20% or should
we settle at 40% and paid off today okay
so how old is the debt it's about six
years six years yeah
you've not paid on it in six years
absolutely we have paid on it within
that time but I I don't know that he
told my husband's taking care of it I'm
calling him because he can't call today
okay so he has neither details but this
is I mean how long do you think it's
been since they've gotten any money from
you maybe four years a long time was it
a credit card yeah yeah and you offered
them $2,000 and they came back and said
$4,000 correct just a one phone
conversation three three calls in the
last two weeks three months and you have
$4,000 yeah okay if you can get it in
writing I'd take care of it but oh it
must be the offer must be in writing
okay and I don't think you're dealing
with Wells Fargo if it's a four-year old
debt they have sold it to a debt buyer
and that's who you're dealing with who
probably paid a nickel on the dollar for
it and you're offering them 40 cents on
are they're offering you 40 cents on the
dollar but if you've got the money and
you can clear the debt there's no shame
in that it's
not a bad thing be sure before you give
them any money you have in writing that
says this $4,000 settles this debt in
full all obligations after that are 0
okay and do not give them electronic
access to your checking account when
you're settling a debt okay all right I
have one more question okay sure
so when we get this paid off we will be
done and I'm wondering if it's okay to
pause between baby steps two and three
is not normal and take all the money
we've been using since snowball and
thirds a little or should we just roll
it right in this I would do that I would
do that only after you get your
emergency fund in place because if you
splurge a little and you have a
transmission going you're out on your
car you're screwed
and then the splurging would look stupid
would not do vacations I would not
splurge I would not whine I would finish
and have an emergency fund because it's
gonna bite you kiddo and you can do
whatever you want to do you're your
grown-ups I mean you're allowed to do
you're you're illegal you're allowed to
do whatever you want to do but you're
asking me and I'm saying if you not buy
even if you're debt-free walking around
with no money and savings for
emergencies you are sending out an
invitation that says hey Murphy come
mess up my life if it can go wrong it
will I have noticed that most often when
I am broke is when crap breaks stuff
steam seems to work better when I'm not
broke it's the weirdest thing
so don't know no whining no thumb
sucking put on your big-girl pants and
finish the program that's what you got
to do and it's good for you and you when
you're sitting there with $10,000 in the
bank and you don't have any payments
then you're ready to go splurge a little
bit and if something breaks you got
$10,000 you know some kind of a problem
happens that that's it's after baby step
three that you let your foot off the gas
and you can go back out to eat you can
go on vacation you can buy a couch you
can do
whatever long as you pay cash for it but
until you get there your life is an
emergency looking for a place to happen